a constant staple of the battle shonen
or shonen in general brother characters
tend to have a lot of the cool moments
where they can show off while these are
often done to contrast with the
protagonist some of the heroes and main
characters are brothers themselves so
for today we'll be going through some of
my favorite showcases of outright power
from brothers in anime what i'd like to
feature some moments of mental
gymnastics from brother characters i
figured that these ones are far more
common if you're up to react as some of
my favorite showcases of power from
other characters then strap yourselves
in
fire force has a shorty but it sure made
a great impression
the first truly antagonistic example on
the list we have show gracing us with
his presence for those who've watched
fire force you know which moment i'm
talking about it's one of the most
pivotal moments in the vulcan's workshop
arc and it's his reunion with shinra
shinra is overjoyed to see his brother
again unfortunately the same sentiments
can't be said of show who quickly
attacks reacting with disgust sho
proceeds to quickly defeat shinra in a
battle that was barely won even when
arthur tries to intervene sho easily
makes quick work of him granted arthur
came from a hell of a fight but he also
spent quite a lot of said fight showing
off only to get one shot at here i say
the antagonist can really use a very
impactful introduction and while it's a
short moment i think the scene does that
and more for show it showed off part of
his personality in a way that fans can
quickly remember him for him soloing
shinra and arthur in short order is just
a cherry on top
we proceed now with sabo in one piece
you talking
you know
[Music]
on the topic of one piece everyone will
be expecting someone like ace given the
context of this list however i
personally like to shine the spotlight
on luffy's lesser known brother well
brother in a technicality's sake among
sabo's moments my absolute favorite case
of him showing his power is when he
shows up in dressrosa disguise and all
his impressive prowess remains case in
point the moment when he demolishes the
entire arena with a combination of
dragon claw fist and dragon breath or
while the audience looks on in
astonishment at the power of this guy
sarvo's really an impressive character
all things considered this is a guy who
was able to use haki at age 17 by the
way no wonder this guy has quickly shot
up the popularity chance to become one
of the most beloved side characters in
one piece
next up is a moment featuring kirito
from sao war of underworld
to say that kirito has a lot of op
flexing moments is quite the
understatement he's got a lot of them
there's the gleam eyes battle where he
came dangerously close to dying or the
ending of ordinal scale but i think that
my favorite one has to be his revival in
war of underworld when you've got an
entire season dedicated to holding the
line and protecting the comatose guy he
better make it all worth it and sure he
did because why not it took a season and
a half to wait for him to wake up but
when he did all it took was some getting
back into form before he manages to show
off the power he gained from defeating
administrator at the end of
alicization's first part he alone
trivializes the entire red army with the
power of his and eugeo swords and he
finishes his long-standing rivalry with
visago showing off an entirely new
arsenal of learned abilities he didn't
get to show before due to falling into a
coma he didn't god mode his way through
versago mind you but at this point it's
clear as day he's literally the only one
with even the slightest chance against
the ark's top villains
next something right in time for the
return of bleach
[Music]
we're talking about
in memories of nobody in the mainline
series byakuya has had a lot of these
cool moments being the prideful and
honorable captain that he is while we
can easily talk about how he easily
defeated renji even when the latter
seemed at the top of the world with his
newly acquired bankai and all i think
that this movie moment feels more apt if
we're taking a simple showcase that
results in a quick stomp what made this
such a great moment is that before this
point the guy's barely in the movie at
all he played pretty much no role
besides saving rookier and easily
eradicating an opponent who's shown to
have given the heroes quite a lot of
fits in their previous encounters rookie
had sure had to work to stay alive and
fight jai to a stalemate but when
byakuya arrives it's all over i guess
his bond guy being perfect in dealing
with multiple clones is a thing to
consider but that doesn't make this
moment any less awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
before we move on to the next moment i'd
like to take time to thank our sponsors
for today's video expressvpn expressvpn
is the number one vpn service that
allows you to access the internet like
never before that includes being able to
watch all of those shows legally even if
you're not in the supported region
because we all know that region locks
can be such a pain i've used expressvpn
to rewatch attack on titan recently and
let me just say that it boasts one of
the most simplest interfaces that i've
ever seen for a vpn just turn on this
bad boy and select the united states
server connect and enjoy some titan
slaying goodness i also want to add the
express vpn proudly presents top tier
protection for your data this way you
can browse the internet without worry
despite the growing worries on cyber
security these days i've been using
expressvpn for as far back as i can
remember and i'll tell you that it has
never ever let me down and i would love
you to join the fun all you have to do
is click the link below and a veil of
the free three month service or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube to get started on a new
safer internet life for you now let's
head back to the video
next up is a battle from seven deadly
sins
[Music]
how far can one protagonist go in a
battle that progressively stacks the
odds against him this is despite how
opie said protagonist is that's the
exact question posed by meliodus's brave
stand against the ten commandments to be
fair he did a damn good job roping
everyone the first time round it's not
every day that you get to see someone
tank all those attacks from top tier
fighters one after another but meliodas
didn't just tank them in fact he used
those attacks to charge the counter
preparing to use them against all the
commandments at once you don't get more
badass than that of course we all know
meliodas got defeated quickly afterwards
on the other hand this fight made esther
rossa look so much stronger what better
way to build a villain up than to have
him quickly one-up the hero who just
showcased his power
foreign
this is a spoiler well fairy tale has
been done for a while already so i guess
it's safe to reveal that zerath is in
fact a brother character i admit this
isn't the conventional power showcase
that we've seen so far with the previous
few moments it's the brother character
showing off his strength or skill in
power but for zeref here it's more shows
superiority you see mod gear here has
been soundly beaten by a herculean
effort from the good guys then xerath
comes in to deliver the cool de grasse
this guy mart gear who'd spent the past
few episodes making life hell for the
heroes immediately turns into a
groveling mess begging for mercy too bad
all it took was a little more than a
snap before he gets shot back to the
depths of xerep's book so much for all
the talk about him being able to kill
the immortal xerif memento mori could
have done the job maybe but the scene
definitely suggests otherwise
following that we have
versus everyone
here's how to leave a massive impression
on everyone gamuwe has always been a
wild card character for me you know the
seemingly strong edgy rival character
type that we so often see in these
shonen he's got quite the reputation but
it's also something that he must defend
he got his chart 24 gin toki in
guintamas episode 326
almost the whole episode is a long
drawn-out fight between the two but what
makes this cooler is that he didn't just
fight gentoki here he had to go through
the whole of yoro zuya and abuto and he
came out of it looking stronger than
ever despite suffering the technical
loss there's no better chance to show
off a character strength than to have
him go one versus many and while kamui
didn't get the honor of delivering a
curb storm battle like a lot of the
traditionally overpowered villains this
fight sure made him live up to his
reputation and more
had spent entire arcs gathering his
forces becoming stronger and discarding
all he thought was worthless all for the
sake of one goal defeating his brother
and avenging the uchiha clan yet when
the two brothers finally meet for their
fated showdown itachi's reaction tells a
different story from the get-go itachi
turns the tables on his headstrong
brother opening the whole encounter with
a boast then he proceeds to outmaneuver
sasuke every bit of the way quickly
shifting momentum of the battle well
let's not pretend that sasuke had it in
the first place to be fair he quickly
recovers and takes the fight to itachi
even if everything seems ineffective the
whole affair turned out to be a touch
and go battle which strongly showed
sasuke's growth but it all began with a
badass boast to hype the showdown up it
really seemed that sasuke had bitten
more than he could chew and it's all
because of hitachi's show at the start
and that's it for this video now this
video and list may be done but i'm still
up for some talking if you want to chime
in i'd encourage comments as they help
with the algorithm but you can also drop
by vinitube's social media channels just
follow the links in the description box
to visit the channel's discord patreon
or instagram i hope you enjoyed watching
this video if you liked it and haven't
subscribed yet then please make sure you
do and don't forget to check out other
videos from the channel looking forward
to seeing you again in the next video